hablamos economía en directo américa de
france 24 dan y ya son varios países en
las que rusia les corta el suministro de
gas y esto porque de raúl porque el
kremlin ordenó que desde el primero de
abril los envíos del hidrocarburo a
países que considera inamistosos debían
ser pagados en rublos y no en dólares o
en euros como dicen los contratos desde
entonces a algunos que se han negado les
han cerrado el grifo como por ejemplo
países bajos bulgaria polonia y
finlandia una lista a la que desde este
miércoles se suman a la empresa osde que
es el principal grupo energético de
dinamarca y también la compañía shell
energy y uruguay que suministra gas a
alemania en el caso danés que no
obstante no recibe el gas desde un
gasoducto directamente desde rusia el
impacto podría representar dos tercios
de su consumo total y en el de alemania
apenas un pequeño flujo ahora ni como
han hecho los otros países que sí siguen
recibiendo ese suministro bueno es que
desde un principio el kremlin planteó
una solución que era la siguiente crear
dos cuentas en gazprombank que es el
tercer banco más grande del país una
para que las empresas ingresen sus pagos
en euros que luego son convertidos a
rublos en la bolsa de moscú y se
ingresan a una segunda cuenta en la
divisa local rusa las empresas alemanas
italianas y francesas sin embargo han
dicho que participarán en este esquema
de pago de moscú eso para garantizar que
puedan mantener sus suministros vamos
ahora a españa que está a punto de
recuperar sus cifras de turismo
prepandémicas vámonos a españa de
duración de vacaciones y señor raúl pues
casi diez veces más turistas visitaron
españa en abril en comparación con el
mismo mes del año pasado una cifra que
impacta de inmediato las finanzas de un
país cuyo turismo representa el 12 por
ciento de su economía en el cuarto mes
del año visitaron este país un total de
61 millones de turistas frente a los 629
mil del año anterior y su gasto fue de
unos 7.400 millones de dólares esto es
apenas un poquito por debajo de lo que
gastaron en abril de 2019 que era antes
de la pandemia lo que ha detectado el
ministerio de turismo es que los
visitantes ahora se quedan más tiempo y
gastan más que antes de la crisis
sanitaria que tanto golpeó hasta y lo
que he detectado yo es que los tiquetes
también están por la nube y están por
las nubes
han subido un colombiano para ir es para
ir españa y venezuela cree que su
economía está fortalecida bueno el
pasado 16 de mayo raúl el observatorio
venezolano de finanzas que es un ente
independiente integrado por expertos
económicos afirmó que la economía de
venezuela creció un 78 por ciento en el
primer trimestre de 2022 eso con
respecto al mismo período de 2001 y se
debe al repunte del sector petrolero en
más del 40% en parte gracias a los
precios internacionales
una información que es respaldada por
datos de la organización de países
exportadores de petróleo porque ellos
muestran un aumento de la producción en
venezuela del 41 por ciento en este
mismo lapso pero el presidente nicolás
maduro cree que los resultados del
primer trimestre inclusive fueron
mejores de lo que ya vemos de lo que ya
hemos dicho
venezuela ha experimentado un
crecimiento en el primer trimestre
de el año 2022 por encima de dos dígitos
los indicadores todos van
mostrando mejoría primero el crecimiento
de la economía real el crecimiento la
economía real que el año pasado estuvo
por encima de cuatro puntos el primer
trimestre de este año está por encima de
dos dígitos
segundo la estabilidad del sistema
cambiario y su sustentabilidad
excelente en tercer lugar la
desaceleración de la inflación y que nos
trae como cifra el día a daniela blandón
bueno la cifra del día son los 9 euros
raúl en que el gobierno alemán determinó
que podrían comprar un tiquete ilimitado
para los tiquetes de bus o para los
pasajes de bus durante todo este mes
esto con el fin de contrarrestar la alta
inflación en este país lo podrán hacer
durante tres meses seguidos y
finalizamos con los indicadores
económicos tan bueno los indicadores las
bolsas europeas suben modestamente
después de que el precio del barril de
petróleo reanudará una trayectoria
ascendente tras el bloqueo previsto de
la mayoría de las importaciones de
petróleo ruso por parte de la unión
europea mientras que en las operaciones
asiáticas la bolsa de tokio ha van
después de que el parlamento de japón
aprobara un presupuesto adicional de 21
mil millones de dólares para hacerle
frente a la inflación daniele así la
despidió muchísimas gracias por toda la
economía de esta mañana en directo
américa yo la despido para darle la
bienvenida al y méndez para hablar de
los deportes